in simple harmonic motion one of the
most confusing parts of it is you've got
all these different ways to get into a
simple harmonic motion question and
sometimes you don't know which way you
should use or sometimes when you look at
a question it wants you to go a
particular way but you you're not very
comfortable with that so you try another
way that just doesn't work out okay so a
classic example is many questions in
simple harmonic motion say nothing
whatsoever about time right we're used
to when you get like that a sigh and mt+
alpha or cause or something like that
you're like oh I put in a time value I
get a I get a displacement or I get a
velocity or I get an acceleration and I
think we're generally much better at
that because um we start thinking about
it in terms of time but frequently good
morning but frequently we do not do it
in terms of time we do it in terms of
displacement so I want you to remember
these two results it's okay Paul come in
grab a seat when you think about your
derivatives with respect to displacement
we have two particular results one
that's specific to simple harmonic
motion and one that relates to all
different kinds of motions so long as
you're on a straight line okay
so first we'll do this one cuz I think
it's a bit easier to remember when you
know there's simple harmonic motion
there's a differential equation that
relates acceleration to displacement do
you remember what it was it's a really
simple equation yeah negative and
squared X and of course there's a minor
modification to this guy if this is you
know going about the U x equals zero the
origin if you're not going about x
equals zero we just changed this to not
X but X minus B so we'll consider that
example later but this is a simple
version right we know this is basic
vanilla simple harmonic motion but for
all kinds of straight line motion we
have another differential equation that
also has to do with the acceleration do
you remember what it was it's on the
reference sheet it's this weird one
which we had to prove and we went
through this long awkward proof and I
showed you in the moon yeah it's the one
with D on DX of what is this weird thing
that goes in there let's remember it's
half
V squared and you might remember the
half v square comes from integrating V
with respect to X and you get half B
squared you get chain rule and all that
kind of thing okay so this is true only
for simple harmonic motion it comes out
of sine and cosine but this is true for
all straight-line motion right we just
that where did that come from it came
from the chain rule actually I think we
use the chain rule twice right so this
is always true this is true for simple
harmonic motion
a natural thing to do would be to
combine these two since they're both
with respect to X you see that so I
wonder if this is really males and how
many of you could rehearse this proof
for me because you do need to know how
to prove it if I say that this is equal
to that because they're both
acceleration okay then I get this let's
just write it out first all right you've
got this derivative with respect to X a
function in terms of X you're like I
know what to do with this I will just
integrate rent sir if you integrate the
left hand side you should get back to
wherever you came from when you
integrate the right hand side with
respect to X what you get have a think
so this minus a negative N squared is
just a constant it's just a number so
this could be like minus 5x or minus 10x
or something like that so what happens
to the constant at the front the
constant coefficient yeah nothing
happens to it just stays put what about
the X we can integrate with the choice X
it's going to become
yeah x squared on to I'm gonna write it
as a 1/2 x squared like so but even
though I haven't written it good morning
this integration that I've done is is it
definite or indefinite at this point
it's indefinite I have no boundaries or
anything like that which means I need to
include a constant so try that guy over
there ok now I can I can tidy this up a
little bit I see this this awkward half
that's on both sides here so I just
multiply everything like 3 by 2 and that
gives you this - in the squared x
squared
I will point out a handful of textbooks
you might have seen undershirt I wasn't
around with mrs. Lee's prove this result
but a handful of textbook instead of
calling this see they call it half C
because if it's a constant then half of
a constant is still a constant so they
do that so that on this line they just
get C but it doesn't matter because
either way I'm about to find out what
that constant is okay now pause for a
moment when you have an indefinite
integral right and you get handed a
constant in there and your job is to
find out what that constant is what do
you normally do what kind of information
is you generally need a condition of
some kind like an initial condition is
the most common thing to go for time
equals 0 and then X or velocity or
acceleration equals something else you
pop it in and that gets rid of all of
your variables and then you you evaluate
the constant okay now initial conditions
where we normally go but I don't have
anything in terms of time here so
initial doesn't really make sense so I
need to think about something some other
condition that I know about simple
harmonic motion that will allow me to
put values into V and X and then give me
a value for C does that make sense so I
need to evaluate V and X I need
someplace someplace where I know what
the velocity is and then if I can
substitute both those values in I will
be able to evaluate the constant okay
now what you'd have a thought think what
kinds of places do you know what the
velocity is one terms of time what kinds
of displacement join oh the velocity and
I want something nice and simple right
okay so I've got some choices right I
could say oh what about x equals zero
that's kind of kind of like t equals
zero right if I put in x equals zero I
need to know what the velocity is to go
with that right do I know anything about
the velocity of this like the maximum
velocity of this particle at the moment
I don't know anything about this right I
don't know if it's like a really slow
moving thing like a tide that goes up
and down very gently or I don't know if
it's like a an electromagnetic wave
which goes up and down and up and down
millions of times a second I don't know
anything about that so and x equals
I don't have helpful information for the
velocity right are there any other
places in the motion of a simple
harmonic motion object where I actually
do know the velocity any other places I
already tried X equal to zero
hmm Mira and draw a draw a little yeah I
think you worked it out draw a little
simple harmonic motion for me right like
here's sign okay for example that could
be simple hiring mission we considered
when x equals zero that's these spots
here okay we're like well it would be
the maximum velocity of those points but
I don't know what the maximum velocity
it's just not very useful to me have a
look again at the motion of this object
where else do you know the velocity yeah
treefon okay yeah have a look at this
spot or this spot this is the airport
ooh these are the extremes of motion
right one of the things one of the few
things we know about this completely
vague simple harmonic motion is when you
get to the ends you stop moving it's
stationary right what are the values for
the ends of the motion being that I'm
about the origin what would we normally
call that his spot and this spot
it'd be these stray extremes and I don't
know what they are so I'm just going to
call them negative a and a that's what
we usually call the coefficient of our
sine or cosine function right so I can
say over here at x equals a or I could
put in negative a if you like but can
you see it doesn't matter because a X is
going to get squared in a second at a or
negative a I know what the velocity is
it's zero okay and that's because when x
equals a that's an extreme of motion so
it stops okay so this is why why why
would I think of pulling this outwards
because I don't know where else to look
these are the only times I have or the
only positions I have useful information
about the velocity okay so all I'm gonna
do now is I'm gonna sub these in in the
hope of evaluating C so on the left hand
side what will I get
now we look left hand side it's just
gonna be zero because it's zero or
squared
equals minus and squared here comes X so
that's going to be a squared plus my two
see me so you can see it doesn't really
matter whether we call it half C or C
because we're going to find out what
this thing is anyway
tada so now I know what the constant is
at this point I can pop it back in and
get a proper equation here with no
unknown constants flying around N
squared a squared and that N squared
that's out the front of both of those is
kind of begging to be factorized out so
I'm going to do that and watch out for
that double negative so I'm factorized
now occasionally you'll see this written
with that negative factor inside so
you'll see a written like this either of
them are fine but the point of saying
this either of them is to say if you see
an equation like that
which has nothing to do with the
acceleration directly anyway you're like
oh I can recognize that that is simple
harmonic motion and I can do stuff with
that okay so as a quick example I'm
going to pull out you don't even have to
look it up cause it's so brief I'm gonna
pull that two of the HSC questions that
you have access to on canvas that use
this exact result and I'll show you how
to use them okay so the first example
they just give you an equation here we
go it's just multiple choice okay which
is important our point point out why in
a second so all you need to do is state
something about this and they're
particularly asking for what's the
amplitude what's the period okay so I
want you to have a look at this result
we just proved this result here which
part tells me about the amplitude which
pretty rule it's the we even named it
appropriately because amplitude right
it's a right it's this guy so whatever I
can see there excuse me is going to
correspond to the amplitude squared so
there's it's equivalent so what would
you say the amplitude is just by reading
it off it's just three nine is three
squared a squared will be three sorry a
will be 3 because a squared is nine
okay that's really nice I'm also gonna
be asking about the period now the other
number here is N squared so if N squared
is 16 then and is 4 but that's not the
period how do I get the period out of
that number
yeah very good normally a normal tree
function it goes all the way up limb to
2pi but if you had say sine 2x it goes
up to only pi right you're dividing by
whatever n happens to be so therefore if
I see any equals for there I can say
therefore the period is 2pi on that
number which of course just simplifies
out and you have your result okay now
while I rub off the left-hand side of
the board to make space for the Knicks
and the final example I'm just going to
show you it's important to mention this
is a multiple choice question which is
why we can just state it okay but
normally you actually do have to go
through integration and show this that's
why I went through the effort of read
arriving is for you because you need to
know how to do it mercifully it's quite
easy to do if you remember this which is
on the reference sheet and this which is
the basic thing for simple harmonic
motion you just need to remember to
combine them okay and then the
integration kind of falls out quite
nicely